[Music]
good morning John it's Friday October
5th
I've got your video cued up when you
talk about the feuds thinking I would
just sort of listen in and tell you what
I think of the things that you mentioned
dragons or fairies dragons parents
aren't even well-trained would be a good
show though unicorns okay well I think
we've got a good place to start them
with unicorns or zombies kind of hard to
argue about something that doesn't exist
though we have had arguments in
Brotherhood 2.0 who remember the whole
Obama Edwards thing I mean the whole
reason that Brotherhood 2.0 hasn't been
able to endorse a candidate is that
Barack Obama has a problem with coal and
this apparently is not something that
bothers you maybe it's because outside
doesn't have the kind of influence over
you that outside should have broke my
box
geez Oh chuckle 'it can we Feud about
cheese or chocolate on a cheese man
myself there are just more kinds of
cheese than there are kinds of talk ups
I feel like I would be giving up more
sexy fill or what the buck but I know a
sexy fill no offense to the buck I'm
just more in sexy bills demographic I
think Star Trek the original series or
Star Trek The Next Generation star check
the next generation kung-fu or come
through the Legend Continues actually I
mean if you said come through the Legend
Continues then we would actually have a
feud on our hands Huey Lewis in the news
back in time or Huey Lewis and the news
ghostbusters that one's really hard the
neverending story or Goonies Goonies
never say die it's our time our time
down here it occurs to me that the
Goonies may possibly have been the
original nerdfighters nerdy Asian kid
who's inventing stuff all the time and
then there's Mikey who out all the
braces and couldn't speak correctly and
was always saying the wrong word at the
wrong time and then there was mouth who
was just ridiculously smart and then
there's chunk who's chubby also there's
Slough root canals occurring to me
people who want for the 42.0 where do
you watch The Goonies and that is a
horrible tragedy young nerdfighters if
you have never watched beauties go read
the duties it's like Harry Potter except
there are pirates and it takes place in
the real world or at least the real
world as it was in 1985 that friendship
that and being social outcasts underdogs
to something that we know a good deal
about here in nerdfighter town anyway
was I talking about feuds you can easily
see if John Edwards becomes a little bit
more of a substantial candidate in this
race that could be a real feud because I
do like John Edwards a lot they like to
listen to Barack Obama I would love to
listen to him for the next four years I
just want to hear his voice
its pleasant sometimes I feel like his
priorities are not stacked in the same
order as my priorities I think that all
of his priorities match up well with my
priorities but I think his isn't a
different list it's a different order my
opinion it's not gonna matter all that
much if there's really good health care
in America if we can't feed ourselves
because we poison theóthe in fact
anybody who brings al gore into their
cabinet to be like chief of
Environmental Affairs and climate
research yes that person that would vote
for I don't care who the hell it is I
don't even care which party it is
someone who actually show us that they
am give a about the environment
that's the one that I'm going for
hopefully that's enough material for a
feud for you because I think it probably
is pick it on universal health care no
that's how to piss off John Green
Brotherhood to calm in my pants maybe
down for a little bit this weekend
because we're moving to a new server and
that is probably all that I'm gonna say
today Katherine and I are gonna go in a
walk I'll see you on Monday